I'm excited to introduce our ceremony
speaker someone who has just been
awarded the an honorable and on a
Doctorate from Carnegie Mellon
University for her huge accomplishments
towards the field of computer science
sheffy Goldwater is undergraduate alumna
of Carnegie Mellon she received a
bachelor's degree in 1979 in mathematics
by mathematics why not computer science
because we didn't weird she didn't have
a computer science department back there
back then which is hard to imagine but
she was one of the first generation of
major computer scientists produced by
this school even then she was way ahead
she was also among the very few women
studying computer science in those days
she went on to master's and PhD degrees
from Berkeley where her advisor was
curing Award winner manuel Blum who is
now of course one of our esteemed
members of faculty here at Carnegie
Mellon University she spent her career
at MIT and the Weizmann Institute and is
best known for her work on cryptography
winning many awards for really quite
astonishing situations where using
mathematics underlying the number theory
that we need she on at least three
occasions in her career completely
turned on their heads previous
assumptions of what you could actually
do with cryptography among her many
awards for this is the Turing Award the
highest possible award in the in the
world of computer science in 2012 along
with Silvio McCauley also a student at
Manuel's she recently took on the
directorship of the Symons Institute for
the theory of computing in Berkeley
where we're all expecting and we know
with full confidence she will continue
to lead in the field of computer science
and create amazing new technology for us
so please join me in welcoming Shafi to
say a few words
thank you for that incredible
introduction thank you so dear students
parents colleagues really standing here
before you is very special for me
because it does complete a circle in my
life I started my academic life here at
Carnegie Mellon in 1976 it was a math
major and then later eyes focused on
computer science I came from Israel and
somewhat of a whim to join my brother
whose area in the audience i Nathan he
was a math undergraduate here as well
then he went to business school and
there weren't too many foreign students
at the time at Carnegie Mellon I think
I've heard that now it's about 15% is
undergraduates and I still remember that
somebody asked me in Skibo which was the
cafeteria then when I said that I came
from Israel is whether my family has a
camel they didn't and in fact I don't I
didn't know anyone who did and you know
things like you know in the break
between the semesters they would close
down the graduate dorm because nobody
everybody went home but I went to spend
the Christmas break with my brother who
was in the graduate doorman match and
you know I'm sort of falling up on top
or his speech it really was an effort
right I mean this see me was generous in
giving loans but you know I worked in
Roy Rogers downtown does anybody know
what my Rogers is the parents probably
and I had a very thick Israeli accent
which I still have a little bit today
and I didn't know how to say howdy
partner and big holster coming up so
they fired me they said I said it
incorrectly or something and I do
remember that the other workers they
were very anxious for me and they said
what is going to happen you're not gonna
be able to go up to McDonald's and okay
anyway so at that time as was just
mentioned you know there was no computer
science major which is kind of amazing
it seeing all of you if you wanted to
study computer science which I didn't
because I didn't know anything about it
you know as a math major and I did this
math studies sequence but if you and
then I heard about that there was this
very good computer science department
and there was a computer science track
so that's what I did they sort of went
from the math study sequence to study
take computer science courses and
without realizing and essentially almost
by chance because I really just followed
my brother here I found my life's
calling really here in Carnegie Mellon I
was exposed the most amazing courses
teachers ideas at Carnegie Mellon at the
time the field was truly beginning you
know you never know that you're in the
beginning but I was at the beginning and
you know I remember classes with
legendaries like Raj Reddy and Nico
Hoberman and Mary Shaw and John Bentley
and most of all I started doing research
here so as an undergraduate I worked on
this project called CM star you probably
don't know what it is it was 16 small
computers attached together with a
shared memory and the question was how
do you program such a thing and what do
you do with it even is what is it good
for and that it was I didn't realize
that this was really a revolutionary
question even today we don't necessarily
you know all the answers to that as a
guy here knows but this was thrown as
B's an undergraduate and to come up with
some application on the same star and I
was working with a graduate student and
I thought it's probably a lot of you
think when you start doing research is
that I just didn't know the answers but
somebody else knew the answers but it's
just not true nobody knew the answers
and I didn't realize how hard it was and
how innovative it was and this kind of
brings me back to Carnegie Mellon as a
whole it's always been an incredibly
innovative place a pioneer in computer
science sort of a beginning to today and
you know I went to you know I went to
California because Raja Reddy who really
paid attention to me as an undergraduate
gave me a recommendation and got me this
job at Rand in Santa Monica and then I
drove up the coast and fell in love with
Berkeley but my point being is that up I
was in Carnegie man I was in Berkley
then I was at MIT but I kept paying
attention to what was happening at CMU
and there were all these things you know
this initiative that every student would
have a personal computer it started here
you know then we adopted it and my team
of the Athena project you know know
Hands Across America this autonomous
vehicle the robotics project it just
kept striking me that how original and
innovative this place has always been I
guess you have now this artificial
intelligence and the graduate major is
also first the fact that they're
international campuses
all around the world of Carnegie Mellon
I think this is sort of was pioneered
here this idea so I don't know if you
know that but this is an incredibly
innovative place and you should pay
attention in the future as you go along
to see what happens here and what else
didn't want to say that I remember here
especially so there's the innovation
there are these wonderful teachers the
fact that the people of Pittsburgh which
most of the undergraduates were pistols
were from Pittsburgh then had a
fantastic sense of humor I never knew
people could be so funny but they were
another thing is that this is like the
776 to 79 there were very strong women
mentors around here there was Anita
Jones there was Mary Shaw there were
very powerful presence in the department
you know I there were people that I
looked up to and I know this is still a
part of public part of the you know
conversation but I didn't actually
realize it at the time because these
women were so kind of up front there and
present so this was all about personal
you know about me about how honored I am
so just saying a few more general things
as you know this is a yeah is no longer
exactly a young field it's not such an
old field when I start in cryptography
there was this paper by different
Hillman that said we are on the brink of
a revolution I think it's completely
true again now that we are on the brink
of a revolution that somehow it's been
recognized that these automated
data-driven algorithms can change the
world in so many disciplines and of
course there's a lot of warnings because
when you change the world you might sure
you do it too quickly without realizing
what you're doing but it's an incredible
period it's like wow if I had to choose
what I was going to major in today I
would do the same except this time it
actually makes sense and then he was
sort of by chance
another thing you know because I'm a
theorist I would say that don't forget
the importance of basic research and the
importance of recognizing a good idea
when it comes out even though it's not
clear that it was made to solve a
particular application tomorrow but I
can honestly tell you that I find look
at all the big revolutions we have in
the computer science it all started with
some ideas in some paper which is about
the fundamentals and it may take a 10
years it may take 20 years sometimes may
take 30 years and then you see it come
to
and maybe change the world from impact
on industry impact on money impact on
governments even well I was just telling
me that maybe world peace you know there
is a lot that can be done there's a lot
of wisdom from the past and you have got
the wisdom to generate ideas for the
future so I want to congratulate you and
I'm going to keep watching what happens
thank you
[Applause]